[Música]
usted está aquí oh eso queremos creer
usted está aquí habitando un espacio
determinado que se rige por leyes
conocidas tener los pies sobre la tierra
es lo aceptado lo bien visto sin embargo
caer es algo que nos enseñaron a evitar
lo más posible aún así todos hemos caído
tropezado y vuelto a caer demás en este
momento seguramente en algún aspecto de
su vida que tenemos calle el vértigo de
la incertidumbre es una sensación
familiar y constitutiva de la
experiencia humana porque al llegar la
porque acá en la sociedad que exalta la
base acartonada de seguridad que
representa a la tierra firme proponemos
resignificar la caída analizar la
pregunta en caída que están callados ya
que incluso caminar caminar
y dejar actuar a la gravedad reconocido
y usar a su favor para que nos lleve a
donde elijamos somos seres en caída
constante es el extitular en donde nos
hacemos fuertes reconocer la propia una
vida evitarla y reconocerla en otro bien
de redes que pueda amortiguar el golpe a
encaminarnos hacia aquello que se nos
presenta como desconocido nuestra caída
eso eso es un salto
saltemos juntas y juntos bienvenidos y
bienvenidas a que x la plata
[Aplausos]
[Música]